what is going on everybody welcome to
part 9 of our Python with PI QT for
creating gooeys tutorial video series
what we are going to be talking about
today is a progress bar so like I was
saying QT just comes with a lot of
little widgets that just make your life
easier and one of the more popular
things that you're going to see in
Windows is a progress bar but to do a
progress bar and tkinter is a little
more difficult to do on wx-- Python a
little more difficult doing a progress
bar in PI QT is a breeze so let's go
ahead and show a quick example so we're
going to make a progress bar and we're
going to have it be part of our homepage
so we're going to come down here and
let's just add some progress bar code so
we're going say self progress equals QT
GUI dot Q progress bar and past self
then we're going to set the geometry to
this progress bar you don't have to but
I like to kind of modify it so we're
gonna say self dot progress dot set
geometry and we're going to set the
geometry to 200 by 8 hunt well it's
going to be starting 200 X 80 Y and then
it will be 250 wide and 20 pixels tall
next what we're going to do is you can
have a progress bar okay but if you just
have a progress bar like I don't know
you have to have something that like
makes it go right so we're going to make
a quick button that just says like
download okay it'll just be kind of sudo
download but it will make it anyway so
you've already seen buttons but we'll do
self dot B TN equals cute oops
QT GUI dot Q progress progress progress
oh whoops whoops cutie GUI and Q push
button instead and we want this button
to be download and self then self dot
BTN
a dot move and our other let's see this
is at two hundred by eighty so let's
make this two hundred one and it'll be
eighty so 20 to 120 that should be fun
and then we'll do self daunt BTN click
connect and then self dot download okay
so we need to make this download method
now again we're not gonna actually
download anything but we're going to at
least make the progress bar go so we'll
come on down here and we'll make a new
method and this one is obviously going
to be defined download pass in self and
now let us go self dot completed so
we're you know just establishing a
starting point here so self dot
completed equals zero and then we're
going to say Wow self comple did is less
than 100 because we want to stop at 100%
self dot completed plus equals and we'll
just use your point zero zero zero one
two don't make it go slow enough and
then we'll go self dot progress dot set
value and then self dot completed so
whatever completed is and then so just
just keep adding this point zero zero
zero one until it hits a hundred but
it's also going to set the value of our
progress bar whatever self dot completed
is and our progress bar is obviously up
here and the value is you know how much
complete are we like five percent 10
percent 20 percent so on so let us go
ahead and run this bad boy cool so now
we've got our window and we ever
download we can click it and wouldn't
you know it it downloads stuff we can
keep downloading it like we are
ultra-fast downloaders anyway pretty
cool progress bar and again you know we
didn't have to do any like of the
graphics here for this progress bar we
didn't need to really code you know the
we coded the dimensions of it but we
didn't even code this little percent
showing over here really none of that
and it even has the little loading like
I don't know effect of whatever computer
you're using
I'll show you later how we can change
the styles of the window once we have a
lot of stuff on here and in fact we'll
probably just go ahead and do that in
the next video so so you can see how you
can change the style because depending
on what operating system you're running
this is probably looks a little
different the whole window probably
looks a little different and that's the
magic of QT so anyways really QT needs
to hire me as like a salesperson because
I think I'm doing a pretty darn good job
anyway that's it for the progress bar
lots of people were asking about a
progress bar on the tkinter series and
honestly I don't know how to make one
with simply but this you can do it so
quickly and easily and you just pass the
value of the bar and it's like BAM done
so that's all so anyways that's it for
this if you guys have any questions or
comments up to this point please feel
free to leave them below otherwise as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions until
next time